ينضم الينا من موسكو مراسل
عباس مازن اهلا بك بدايه نتوقف عند الشان
الاوكراني هناك حديث في اوكرانيا عن تقدم
واسترداد للاراضي بينما موسكو تعلن من
جهتها بان الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني فشل
فما لديك حول هذا الموضوع
يعني كما ذكرت هذه الصحيح موسكو تتحدث عن
ان الهجوم الاوكراني فاشل سبب في خسائر
هاري هائله في المعدات والارواح وبحسب
بيانات وزاره الدفاع اليوم
موسكو نفذت او القوات الروسيه نفذت قصف
صاروخي تمكن هذا القصف الصاروخي من تدمير
مستودع بصواريخ ستورم شادوها البريطانيه
وذخائر ذات محتوى من اليوراني والمنظم كما
ايضا قصفت القوات الروسيه مصنع للدبابات
يستخدمه القوات الاوكرانيه لاعاده ص
التاهيل الدبابات والمدرعات بالاضافه ليها
تصدي لعمليات القصف الصاروخي الاوكراني
سواء على مدينه في اقليم او في اقليم
كورسك ايضا يقوم نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
القومي الروسي لمتر بجوله تفقديه في ساحات
تدريب بالقرب من خطوط التماس
للمتطوعين المتعاقدين في قيمي دانيتسكو
هذا ما جاء في بيانات وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ولم يدور الحديث عن اي تقدم سواء
للقوات الروسيه او الاوكرانيه مازن في شق
اخر بعد ساعه من مغادره زعيم كوريا
الشماليه
روسيا في زياره كانت لافته وزير الخارجيه
الصيني اليوم يبدا زياره لافته ايضا الى
موسكو تستغرق اربعه ايام ماذا عن هذه
السياره ماذا نعرف عن هذه الزياره
يعني يفترض انه خلال الساعات القادمه
وتحديدا مساء اليوم سيبدا لقاء وزيري
خارجيه روسيا والصين وبحسب تصريحات
الرسميه من وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه سيتم
بحث سبل تسويه الازمه الاوكرانيه وملفات
وقضايا امنيه وزير الخارجيه الصيني سيلتقي
ايضا بسكرتير مجلس الامن القومي
لمواصله لمناقشه وبحث هذه الملفات
والقضايا الامنيه
بحث تقديرات او توقعات المراقبين في موسكو
فان الحديث الان يدور او موسكو تسعى عمليا
في مفاوضات مع الصين او الدول التي تعتبر
منبوده وفق المنطق الغربي لتاسيس قطب في
المنطقه يكون المحور الاساسي في الصين
باعتبارها حليف استراتيجي لروسيا في الشرق
الاقصى
ومن المعروف ان بوتين قد تحدث عن ان هناك
توسع في مختلف المجالات التعاون بين روسيا
والصين ليس فقط السياسي وانما ايضا
الاقتصادي والعسكري كان مساعد الرئيس
الروسي يوري اوشاكووف قد اشار الى انه
يمكن ان يقوم رئيس بزياره الى بيكين الشهر
القادم
ويعقد لقاء مع نظيره الصيني على هامش
منتدى حزام واحد طريق واحد ما زلنا عباس
مراسل
شكرا جزيلا